[Applause]
mom call Grandpa cuz I want to know
what's going on remember your
grandfather was a police officer for 35
years Authority is your elders remember
please I raised you better hello hi hey
how you doing good how are you
conducting a traffic stop because of the
tent okay okay have you ever been pulled
over for the tent before no well I
haven't but she has B I've already
gotten a ticket I'm going
to what's that
was I bought the like this was huge so
I'm going to remove the T and at my
they
okay
okay I'm going to give you back
your insurance and
that I'll just run this do you have any
issues with your license or anything
like that no sir okay where you headed
to um to take her to work and then go
pick my husband up and work and what's
your name ma'am Jennifer Jennifer all
righty all right give me one second okay
no
problem that's weird huh show me out my
for walk up huh I said that's weird
huh okay that Zara person is the person
that this yeah you want to get try to
get the um the passenger ID
too the front and back could
try I'll walk up there with
[Applause]
you
huh okay do you have your ID with
you do
what no we're just I was just asking
whose car it
is thank you you're social I don't need
that don't
[Applause]
ever
she looks completely different than she
does in in the
picture I wonder if she just dyed her
[Applause]
hair well there you go got to go grab it
he says grab her
[Applause]
okay he miss Percy can you jump out for
me
[Applause]
please
back what's wrong do you have anything
you have any weapons on you or anything
like that no what am I being arrested
for can I be read my rights yeah just
wait two
seconds mom call
Grandpa I want to know what's going
on he didn't even
[Applause]
tell I'm
confused 15 bra
11 okay
um basically there was 21's got over
your apartment complex and you were
identified as the one who was shooting I
never
sh well that's beyond me they done a
full investigation theyve done investiga
every day they have video
you okay so that you want your
phone give it to your mom yeah um can I
talk to my mom real
quick stay mom can you just uh mom
answer the phone for any joke calls okay
uh when 386 888 calls answer and tell
him my phone okay tell it was for I
guess I guess think I shot at
somebody
[Applause]
to yeah we'll get it today Mom you got
to call off work call off work you
already call her 10
102 we want to thank Morgan and Morgan
for sponsoring this video now before you
say oh great another Law Firm ad first
of all how dare you speak that way of
Morgan and Morgan and second of all you
don't know what makes them special you
see Morgan and Morgan has completely
modernized the personal injury claim
process they make it super easy for you
you submit your claim you sign contracts
you upload documents you talk to your
whole legal Team all on your phone and
you can text your legal team throughout
your case as much as you want yeah I
said team they have 4,000 support staff
I can't even get anyone here to get me a
coffee a tea a soda and let me tell you
I get parched it's no longer the days of
back-to-back meetings and consultations
an attorney is going to review your case
with eight clicks on your phone that's
it now you might be saying oh that
sounds pretty expensive well here's the
kicker there's no upfront fee no you
only pay them if you win so it's no
wonder over three million people call
them every year if you're injured you
can submit a claim at
www.the.com law and crime or by dialing
pound law that's pound 529 on your phone
arrest um she will have a bond believe
it's $2,500 a question do you know the
sh where uh they they do um the exact on
the report
right was it outside my
apartment I mean I wasn't I wasn't there
so if so I'm
pissed I don't I mean it was in South
Tona so
I don't know the exact details she tell
me to call she's just the registered
owner of the vehicle so she's my
daughter I'm a
mom he has my ID too no he didn't take M
he he didn't take
mine yes ma'am I'm not issuing any
citations or anything can I can I get
out and get it if you want
yeah she's going to step out to come
grab the jewelry
okay
just St by the front of the car you
[Applause]
would
I
mom get
down okay okay
listen I don't know what's going on but
there's one more
he's I love you your baby loves you he
will be fine I need you to stay I'm
going I am okay a lawyer okay his name
isve
should him that's the only lawyer that
I'll you come over here okay we good I
told her scay with you I don't think I
got any more got a
coule I'll leave those on those are
protection racist well they're going to
make them take you off they can't take
they have to no they can't Zer please
when you go in there don't act a fool
listen remember your grandfather was a
police officer for 35 years Authority is
your elders remember please I raised you
better andom me me twist off the ground
I can't I have
[Applause]
nail if you act bad zero they will take
a they'll treat you like you're treating
you call
her can you call her treat take bra
[Applause]
11 female 1015 a email nearby can assist
with
Sur let me get what
they thank
[Applause]
you ow does that hurt I don't know that
felt really gross and I'm it looks like
it hurts
I love
you you want
bag write my M's number
down I like ch right on my hand and I
can always have but if they
take
you that's 11 apologies you busy when
came
my
[Applause]
pass knows it
too answer that call I
will and when you go in there treat him
with respect I know yes ma'am
yes I promise we'll treat you they will
even in the jail please get a hold of
the lawyer okay you have to remember
they're not your enemies I know they're
doing their job I love
you okay guys
I can go yeah if you have any question
all right do you what what address do
you live
at to anybody recently about this
incident uh not I didn't know she was
involved but the other night there was
there was a shooting over by our area
and that's why I said was it around my
house because they didn't know who did
it
question are you to register vehicle no
she
is
yeah we just want to make sure the
firearm supposed to be in the trunk of
the vehicle oh my I would be pissed if
so hate guns we want
to and if I would have known y were
looking for me I would have talk like
there's no problem with that like I
didn't even know so in the girl she
didn't tell me you didn't stand by
subscri Boulevard and Air
black Dodge
R
[Applause]
43 um do you know his
number we just don't want Mom to get
him close it and you can give me the
well I don't want to be around can you
can you grab her
phone half of my screen is broke so
we're going to have to manage okay now
go
out theot B I use Android I don't to the
bottom left right
down sorry guys no stop stop SC
go over here right here
oh
[Applause]
c yeah there you go see you got it okay
now
search good stop
there saw him did saw it we both he
drove right past
us he he keed up on
T I'm I'm trying to
think how it how it got past me it do a
U-turn or it came out it hit the
Ridgewood and I was right there you saw
me you drove right past me that's
weird I wonder if it picked it up could
if she came off
[Applause]
Bellwood like if she's turning left will
that pick that
up or I mean turning right I mean I
think so offood yeah I think
so cuz I'm like and and I and and
literally the car that that just drove
past me pulled into 1888 really
so so I literally got right right behind
the the last car that I saw you know
what I'm
saying we can go yep you give them their
idas and stuff yeah are they we're not
looking through the car or anything she
she said she gave the gun back to her
sugar
[Applause]
daddy and she just told me that she
didn't shoot at the girl she shot up any
hair she was scared the girl was going
to beat the out of
her
you read her before that no I just asked
her if we can look for the
[Applause]
gun
okay good job you I haven't heard
anything back from Central about a
female Chino has done a 707 like that
where he's copied and pasted I'll call
him and uh have a meet up with you okay
um because remember when we had that
affidavit one time copied it into a uh